to be in Las Vegas well you guys are
bringing the authentic Mexican to Las
Vegas and I'm super excited because I
literally walked up and I was like what
is this and tell everyone what this is
this is our blue corn Masa we make it
fresh to order it gives us our tortillas
so delicious and you um are very famous
for your Vampiro tacos right tacos
you're gonna have a little taste of that
today I'm excited let's start making
them tell us a little bit about what it
is what makes this Taco so popular oh my
God it's the cheese it's the layers it's
the flavors it's the spice so we put our
butter down first just to get a nice
little crispy shell
I'm loving that you guys make I mean all
of the ingredients are fresh this is all
like crazy nothing's canned everything's
made fresh to order we put some cheese
so this is our Mexican cheese blend
can't go wrong okay I love cheese so I'm
gonna back extra cheese
this is so delicious and then I don't
know how spicy you like it spicy but
spicy we're gonna bring it up a notch
I'm like the more spices yeah we use
serrano peppers
so it's a little intense and you're
waiting two tortillas we use two
tortillas it's kind of like a quesadilla
we'll put more butter because more
butter more better baby
where where are you guys located we're
located at the shops at The Forum Shops
at Caesars
um
we're a little tucked away in the corner
I believe there's like an Italian place
next door yeah you're down over by um
like Joe's and stuff like that so you
definitely go check it out I love that
you're bringing like authentic Mexican
here to Las Vegas this is uh and you do
your everything like fresh the guac is
fresh everything's fresh okay what else
so then after that we get our little
quesadilla going we'll put some guac on
there and I'm good with the guac and
it's not extra there is it it's not
extra it's all included there's no
surprises we love that and then we we
can go ahead and put so we have a choice
between our grilled chicken or our carne
asada today I brought our grilled
chicken because I'm a chicken eater
so we're just going to put it right on
top there what are some of your other
Specialties while you finish up this
Taco that you guys have there so we also
have our guacamole Granada which is
really delicious we have our octopus we
have oh we have our chipotle sauce what
makes the guacamole Granada different
than regular Wok so I mean everybody you
know they have their plain guac but we
like to Spruce it up a bit this one's
um we put our Granada our spicy nuts we
put our beet chips delicious I love
beets we put our apples
it's really good and then so now I'm
placing our pico de gallo right on top
okay
we've got like 20 seconds left I'm
excited let me speed it up a little bit
a little uh is that and then this has
got the hot cheese and then we have our
spring of cilantro awesome so good and
then we're just gonna go ahead and plate
it on here for you oh my gosh I love
that it's like a quesadilla and a taco
in one so I just like fold it up yeah oh
my gosh Fold It Up take a bite I'm gonna
take a huge bite of this
but before uh before I send it to
Kendall again tell everyone where it is
and uh you guys are now open right we're
now open Monday through Friday or
through Saturday and Sunday too I assume
dude oh add Saturday and Sunday not
forget the weekend brunch it's uh 10 a.m
to 10 p.m
um on weekends Fridays and Saturdays we
close at 11. the shops amazing The Forum
Shops at Caesars thank you so much
Kendall Alexander already